commence cette audition sur le Président
Madame la Directrice si vous en êtes
d'accord et c'est mes collègues voilà en
sont d'accord
monsieur le Président cher Thierry
Repentin on est très heureux de vous
retrouver voilà dans cette salle et
d'une façon générale au Sénat Madame la
Directrice Générale mes chers collègues
nous avons le plaisir donc de recevoir
ce matin monsieur Repentin président de
l'Agence nationale de l'habitat
accompagné de Madame Valérie
mancrétellor la directrice générale de
l'agence cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo qui est diffusée
en direct sur le site du Sénat
Lana est au cœur d'un défi absolument
central pour la France la rénovation
thermique des logements et la teinte des
objectifs de la Stratégie nationale back
carbone révisé c'est à dire la
suppression de la quasi-totalité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2050 dans le secteur résidentiel dans le
contexte que nous connaissons
malheureusement trop bien de Chris
ukrainienne et des indisponibilités du
parc nucléaire qui fait l'actualité
désormais tous les matins de la presse
chacun mesure combien 2050 est éloignés
et chacun mesure que le besoin d'un
logement bien isolé est essentiel pour
nos concitoyens qui voient leur pouvoir
d'achat amputés par la hausse des prix
de l'énergie comme la souligner notre
collègue Dominique estrosi-sason dans
son rapport budgétaire dans une région
comme l'île de France 45% des résidences
principales sont classées EF ou G à
Paris c'est deux tiers du parc locatif
privé le défi donc capitale si je fais
le lien avec Paris et Lana se trouve au
coeur des attentes notre rapporteur
soulignait d'ailleurs que si Lana était
en passe de réussir la massification des
aides il lui restait à réussir la
massification de l'accompagnement et des
rénovations globales je ne veux pas
céder à la facilité si gauloise de
critiquer la NA et de l'accusé de toutes
les lacunes en la matière l'agence
connaît actuellement une profonde
transformation un changement d'échelle
dont vous nous parlerez en quelques
années le personnel de l'agence a doublé
les paiements ont triplé le nombre
d'aides à quintuplées cela ne peut se
faire sans accroc c'est évident et nous
tous qui s'y avons l'expérience de la
gestion des collectivités locales en
somme conscient
cependant pour les Français qui ont un
dossier en attente voire en souffrance
depuis longtemps auprès de l'ANAH et qui
ont droit à une réponse je voudrais que
vous puissiez nous dire exactement où
vous en êtes aujourd'hui notamment à la
suite de la décision du 14 octobre 2022
du Défenseur des droits je voudrais
ensuite que vous nous indiquiez quel est
et qu'elle va être l'action de l'agence
sur trois sujets le pilotage de la
rénovation énergétique le développement
de France rénov et l'accélération les
fameuses rénovations globale la Cour des
comptes dans un référé daté du 28
juillet 22 a pointé les lacunes du
pilotage de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments je souhaiterais comprendre
s'il y a un pilote dans l'avion donc
copie semble être une mission
interministérielle les moteurs et les
ailes Lana et la dame le fuselage le
réseau France rénov les passagers les
Français les stewarts et les hôtesses
les entreprises RGE les diagnostiqueurs
et les accompagnateurs avec comme tour
de contrôle un observatoire national de
la rénovation énergétique dont j'avoue
j'ignorais l'existence jusqu'à la
lecture du référé par ailleurs dans à
peine un mois compter du 1er janvier
2023 doit se déployer de déployer mon
accompagnateur rénov imaginé par le
rapport Sichel et créé par la loi climat
et résilience ce sont normalement des
professionnels privés agréés par Lana et
reconnu comme des tiers de confiance
pour aider les ménages à s'engager vers
des rénovations globales voici le
principe j'ai l'impression que nous
savons peu de choses aujourd'hui sur la
mise en oeuvre concrète dans le secteur
où beaucoup de Français ont été victimes
on va dire d'arnaqueurs ou d'aigrefin
pour parler plus joliment enfin comment
l'anacondelle accéléré en matière de
rénovation globale je lisais dans la
réponse d'Elizabeth borne à la Cour des
comptes que l'ensemble des prix ne m'a
pris Renov n'avait pas permis en 2021
d'atteindre la moitié de l'objectif fixé
par la SNBC Lana va recevoir beaucoup de
pouce budgétaire en 2023 mais tout n'est
pas question d'argent qu'elles vont être
les décisions du conseil
d'administration pour réorienter les
travaux pour mesurer effectivement les
résultats atteints voilà monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice générale
je vous passe bien sûr la parole et
ensuite je passerai la parole à
Dominique Estrosi stationne et Daniel
Gremillet qui vous interrogeront puis à
tous les sénateurs présents voilà
monsieur le Président à vous alors il
faut appuyer sur
présidente merci pour votre invitation
très honoré d'être dans cette salle de
la commission des affaires
économiques passant
d'auditeurs à audité en quelque sorte
quelques années après avoir eu la chance
de siéger dans cette salle dans cette
commission sur des questions ou vrai
déjà d'ailleurs madame Estrosi sa sonne
sur les questions de logement à l'époque
alors je suis accompagné de Valérie
manquerait Taylor à la directrice
générale de Lana qui aura réponse à
toutes les questions
évidemment puisqu'on on est un binôme
complémentaire
en vous disant
4 ou 5 choses avant qu'on puisse rentrer
dans les discussions auxquelles nous
essaierons de répondre le plus
précisément possible
madame la Présidente vous avez
en introduction indiquée le caractère
exponentiel en quelque sorte de cette
politique de rénovation et vous avez
raison
puisque en 2018 et 2018 c'est pas si
loin que cela il y avait 75000
rénovations de logements qui se
faisaient
en 2022 on sera à 750 000 c'est-à-dire
10 fois plus de rénovation en 5 ans ce
qui évidemment on y reviendra nécessite
une organisation de l'établissement
public
des moyens totalement différents mais
les cinq choses que je voudrais vous
dire c'est que le sujet que vous abordez
aujourd'hui est un sujet
qui est au cœur de l'actualité sur
plusieurs aspects le pouvoir d'achat de
nos compatriotes dans leur logement
puisque la facture énergétique est une
donnée importante du coup d'un logement
la sobriété énergétique les souhaits de
la nation de moins consommer
d'électricité et les effets aussi sur
leur dérèglement climatique par les
rejets de gaz à effet de serre puisque
le bâtiment et le deuxième émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre après le les
transports et dans le bâtiment la
question des logements est conséquente
et aussi pour parce qu'on n'a pas
toujours cela en tête lorsqu'on se
projette vous avez fait référence à la
stratégie nationale bas carbone c'est
en deux les logements qui seront habités
par nos concitoyens en 2050 pour
80%, ils sont construits puisque dans
les très bonnes années de construction
ne construit jamais plus que 1% du parc
existence ça veut dire qu'en 2050
pour 80% des logements sont déjà
construits et donc chacun comprend que
c'est sur ce parc là qu'il faut de
mettre le paquet si vous me permettez
l'expression donc l'année est au coeur
de ces enjeux et il a pour mission
d'accompagner chaque Français sur le
chemin de la rénovation énergétique
grâce au déploiement de France Renov
dans vous avez pu voir y compris des
campagnes de communication télévisuelles
pour que nos compatriotes sachent quelle
est la porte d'entrée aujourd'hui unique
pour aller chercher des renseignements
dès lors qu'ils ont un projet et au
succès évidemment de ma prime rénove
l'État met des moyens qui sont inédits
pour soutenir cette soviétique publique
puisqu'il y a 3 milliards 500 millions
d'euros
annuel dans un milliard en aide à la
pierre qui sont contractualisés avec les
collectivités territoriales à travers
des produits
qui s'appelle ma prime rénov sérénité ou
ma prime rénov copropriété ce qui est
assez inédit et permet d'obtenir des
résultats en constante progression je
voudrais dire aussi que les territoires
sur ce sujet les acteurs économiques ont
besoin de stabilité réglementaire et
budgétaire sur ce dossier pour continuer
à déployer une politique publique
efficace dans la durée et je dois dire
que le passage du cite que vous avez que
nous avons connu à ma prime rénove
apporte cette stabilité car le cite
chaque année en loi de finance avait des
critères qui pouvaient bouger et donc
c'était très difficile de se projeter
dans l'avenir pour nos ménages dès lors
qu'ils avaient un projet la seconde
chose c'est Renov c'est quand même une
première étape dans la réussite se
mesure au retour que nous avons de la
part des ménages qui ont sollicité cette
aide puisque 89% des personnes
déménagent qui sont venues nous voir se
dit satisfaits de ma prime rénove et que
66% des mêmes ménages indiquent que sans
ce dispositif de ma prime rénove il
n'aurait pas fait les travaux qu'ils ont
engagés sur leur logement c'était de
public a permis de lancer une dynamique
forte de massification des travaux de
rénovation énergétique et depuis 2020
donc il y a pas si longtemps que cela
plus d'un million de ménages en ont
bénéficié et d'abord les plus modestes
puisque 68% des dossiers actés par ma
prime manœuvre concerne les quatre
premiers quartiers de la population donc
les quatre quartilles les plus modestes
et c'est 68% de dossiers consomment 80%
des montants de subventions apportées
par l'établissement public ça veut dire
que la cible d'aider plus ceux qui ont
moins aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
dans les proportions que je vous donne
ce matin ma prime rénov a permis aux
bénéficiaires de s'inscrire dans un
parcours de rénovation qui se veut
écologiquement vertueux avec la
réalisation d'un premier geste et ainsi
introduire massivement la décarbonation
des logements privés car je veux le dire
aussi ma prime rénov est possible pour
tous les propriétaires qu'ils soient
bailleurs
occupons où les copropriétés
la moyenne d'économies conventionnelle
par logement et par an et passer
avec le cite de 3,9 moite par an par
logement à 5,6 mégawh par an par
logement avec ma prime rénov ce qui fait
une augmentation de 44% des gains
énergétiques d'un système à l'autre
ces éléments de satisfaction ne nous
font pas oublier puisque vous l'avez
vous-même indiqué que pour certains
usagers le parcours de demande a pu être
ou peut être mais je veux parler au
passé a pu être compliqué la Défenseur
des droits effectivement a pu faire part
de dysfonctionnement dans lui en faire
par certains usagers qui concernent
selon elles je reprends le rapport 500
dossiers
je voudrais simplement redire que Lana
instruit chaque semaine
25000 dossiers qui arrivent et donc il
faut aussi mettre en rapport 500
dossiers au niveau national que la
Défenseur des droits pointe sur des
dysfonctionnements par rapport au 25000
qu'on reçoit par semaine on est
conscient et d'ailleurs au moment où le
rapport est sorti 50% de ces 500
dossiers avaient été
traités et résolu voilà on est conscient
qu'il peut y avoir des difficultés qui
peuvent être générés par certaines
situations et nos équipes sont
pleinement mobilisées pour apporter
évidemment des solutions dans les
meilleurs délais la troisième chose
selon nous il faut pas opposer la
rénovation globale et la rénovation par
geste pourquoi
parce que y compris de la part de celles
et ceux qui sont en première ligne quand
les ménages viennent les voir on se rend
compte qu'il y a pas une solution unique
au dossier qui sont présentés par les
ménages ni de recettes miracle qui
doivent faire un choix technique et
financier impactant
le bouquet de travaux il est de 30000
euros c'est le modèle de ma primorable
sérénité de 30000 à 70 000 pour une
rénovation performante et globale alors
que pèse déjà sur les ménages un coup du
logement important puisque la dépense du
ménage en moyenne en France c'est 30%
des des revenus auxquels vous devez
depuis quelques mois rajouter le
renchérissement des énergies une fine et
il nous semble qu'il faut offrir au
ménage des choix et faire du sur-mesure
en fonction de leurs besoins et de leur
moyen ma prime rénove permet cette
réponse à chaque situation qu'on soit
propriétaire occupant d'ailleurs ou en
copro en complément le traitement des
ménages qui sont en situation de forte
précarité énergétique qui peut aussi
engendrer des coûts majeurs pour
remettre en état des logements on pense
à l'habitat indigne et dégradé dans les
coûts de remise en état dépassent en
moyenne 60 000 euros par logement voilà
et l'agence apporte également des
solutions de financement pour ces
situations à travers des opérations de
lutte contre l'habitat digne dont
certains j'imagine les connaissent sur
le terrain avec la RHI donc la
résolution de l'habitat insalubre ou le
dispositif du terrorisme la quatrième
chose j'ai dit qu'il y en aurait 5 c'est
que l'ANA finance d'ores et déjà 60 000
rénovations globale c'est à peu près 10%
des aides en maison individuelle en
copro
ma prime rénov sérénité qui est donc le
dispositif adapté de référence pour
financer ces rénovations ambitieuses
vous savez est déclenché s'il y a à
l'issue des travaux 35% de gains
énergétique minimum dans les dossiers
qui sont traités après travaux on n'est
pas à 35% mais on est à 50% constaté en
moyenne avec des financements qui sont
vraiment très incitatifs et un
accompagnement qui est systématique pour
les 600 000 propriétaires modestes qui
ont pu bénéficier depuis 2011 de ce
dispositif et la moitié des rénovations
accompagnées par le dispositif donc dans
je viens de vous parler de ma prisonnade
sérénité permettent de sortir des
logements du statut de passoire
énergétique
il y a aussi le dispositif ma prime
rénove copropriété qui progresse chaque
année
malgré un contexte parce qu'il faut
toujours se remettre dans l'actualité
qui a été très difficile pendant les
deux années de covid durant lesquels les
assemblées générales de copropriété ont
vu leur rythme et leur régularité
fortement remise en cause avec très peu
de décisions qui ont été prises parce
que les conditions normales n'étaient
pas
n'était pas présentes il n'y a eu que
7000 logements en 2020
en copro 12000 en 21
vraisemblablement 25000 en 2022 et donc
on voit qu'on est sur une courbe
croissante et je pense qu'un certain
nombre de dispositions qui ont été pris
réglementaires ou législatifs par l'État
les parlements visant à rénover les
passoires énergétiques d'interdiction de
location d'un certain nombre de
logements vont inciter des propriétaires
à se poser plus sérieusement la question
de la rénovation qui ne le faisait
auparavant notamment dans des copro
alors ça reste insuffisant mais on a des
premières évolutions qui seront
proposées pour 2023 avec notamment une
révision à la hausse des plafonds de
travaux
et déprime pour les ménages les plus
modestes qui sont en attente d'arbitrage
nous avons un conseil d'administration
cet après-midi
dont nous décalons une partie de nos
travaux à un conseil d'administration la
semaine prochaine car les réunions
intermittérielles n'ont pas permis
d'avoir tous les arbitrages que nous
attendions le cinquième point c'est que
l'enjeu maintenant c'est de réussir la
massification de l'accompagnement pour
réaliser les rénovations globales et
énergétiques qui doivent être plus
performantes et pour cela il convient
premièrement réaffirmer le rôle des
collectivités dans le cadre d'un pacte
territorial qui vise à remettre en
perspective le sujet habitat au sens
large pour répondre aux enjeux de
transition énergétiques et démographique
il y a valorisé la force du réseau de
proximité portée par les territoires
avec le soutien de l'État puisque d'un
territoire à l'autre le portage est
évidemment différencié vous avez des
collectivités territoriales qui sont
très mobilisées qui apporte aussi des
compléments de subvention qui d'ailleurs
font que les Lana bonifie ses propres
interventions il y a des accompagnements
financiers il y a à peu près 350
communes en France ce qui est un début
qui par exemple exonère de foncier bâti
les ménages les logements dans les
ménages sont l'objet de rénovation ce
qui dans le modèle économique incite
aussi des propriétaires à s'engager pour
retrouver un équilibre entre ce qu'ils
investissent et ce qu'ils peuvent
récupérer il faut aussi permettre à tous
les ménages d'être accompagnés par un
tiers de confiance c'est très important
qu'ils aient en face de quelqu'un qui
les conseils sur le bon geste par
rapport à leur habitat et non pas
des gens qui leur conseillent quelque
chose
qu'ils sont en capacité de faire que le
conseilleur est en capacité de faire il
faut vraiment se tir de confiance pour
être sûr que lorsque vous allez vous
posez la Porte de France Renov vous ayez
derrière quelqu'un qui va ausculter avec
vous votre habitat et vous dire quels
sont les meilleurs gestes à faire sans
avoir un intérêt à privilégier tel ou
tel type de de travaux et ça c'est la
réponse qu'apportera mon accompagnateur
rénov au 1er janvier
2023 donc d'ici quelques semaines et
d'ores et déjà France Renov permet une
information et des conseils neutres et
indépendants pour faciliter le passage à
l'acte vous le savez c'est désormais
France Renov le service public qui est
cofinancé par l'État les collectivités
qui a mis sous une seule enseigne les
Alecs les associations locales la SPL et
qui a fusionné je peux dire à la fois le
réseau auparavant de l'ADEME et de Lana
avec des effectifs qui ont triplé
puisqu'on est passé de 750 à après 2200
conseillers en deux ans et dont la
professionnalisation n'est pas arrivée
encore à terme pour se déployer partout
d'une façon au massive en 2023 il faut
aussi mesurer plus efficacement selon
nous les gains énergétiques et les
émissions de GES s'éviter pour par un
diagnostic initial c'est à dire à
l'issue avant les travaux et à l'issue
des travaux qui rendra de facto le
parcours de l'usager sans doute un peu
plus complexe mais aussi plus secure
sous réserve que l'harmonisation entre
le DPE et les audits soient aboutis et
fiabilisées il faut aussi poursuivre la
démarche de simplification des aides
notamment laisser deux heures dans le
système et est assez opaque pour une
grande partie nos concitoyens complexes
pas toujours alignés d'ailleurs avec ma
prime Réno sur les critères et qui
participent au développement parfois de
commercial qui sont agressives et peu
scrupuleuses mais aussi des aides en
faveur des bailleurs privés qui sont
soumis aux obligations de la loi climat
résilience engager enfin une véritable
rééquilibrage des aides en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique performante
immédiate ou par
étape à ce jour le cumul de forfait il
reste plus avantageux que le forfait
rénovation globale et aucun des deux
n'est adapté pour financer les
rénovations performantes et aussi mieux
financer
l'isolation voilà indépendamment de
toutes ces actions que nous appelons de
nos vœux simplement vous dire qu'il faut
aussi interroger la capacité parfois des
filières professionnelles
entreprise et artisans mais aussi
l'industrie à s'inscrire dans cette
massification qualitative qui reste à
conforter puisqu'on a aussi sur le
territoire des retours de la part de
ménage qui nous disent qu'ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés à avoir
des devis de la part de des filières qui
parfois sont submergés tant mieux d'une
certaine façon mais mais il y a aussi la
capacité d'organisation de la filière à
mettre en place les moyens pour cette
croissance exponentielle à laquelle je
faisais référence en début de mes propos
je laisse Madame la Directrice Générale
complétée
utilement mes propos merci
merci Monsieur président merci madame la
Présidente de nous avoir invité à cette
audition je pense qu'il est toujours
intéressant de pouvoir présenter en fait
dans le détail ce qui se passe et
peut-être en complément monsieur le
Président de ce que vous avez évoqué
bien rappeler et se rappeler
collectivement que nous sommes sur une
politique publique qui est en forte
progression vous avez donné certains
chiffres mais je veux rappeler la date
de mise en oeuvre de ma prime rénove
l'ouverture du service et l'ouverture de
cette aide c'est faite le 1er janvier
2020 donc c'est une c'est une politique
finalement assez récente et celle et
genre et ce que je souhaite partager
avec vous tous c'est c'est que c'est
évidemment une politique qui s'améliore
en tout cas ce évolue quasiment chaque
année et donc monsieur le Président du
conseil d'administration de Lana vient
de d'évoquer effectivement les pistes
que nous recherchons encore d'évolution
sur les mois et les années à venir
puisque le parc de logement vous l'avez
évoqué également
concerné en matière de rénovation
énergétique et d'une manière générale
d'amélioration de l'habitat il n'y a pas
que la rénovation énergétique
l'amélioration de l'habitat au sens
large du parc privé concerne plus de 20
millions de logements dans notre pays et
donc c'est une politique publique au
cours
sur les trois questions madame la
Présidente que vous avez évoquées donc
le pilotage de la rénovation énergétique
est évidemment un sujet porté par deux
ministères le ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires et le ministère de la Ville
et du Logement donc les deux ministres
en charge de ces sujets
puisque cela concerne beaucoup de
beaucoup d'édifices en fait dans notre
pays et si on en reste aux politiques de
l'habitat évidemment il y a le logement
social sur le pour lequel Lana n'est pas
du tout légitime ni concernée et puis
évidemment ce parc privé que vous
souhaitez que nous évoquions ce matin
pour ce qui nous concerne nous avons
donc créé effectivement ma prime rénov
au 1er janvier 2020 et je pense qu'il
est important de partager avec vous que
ma prime rénov c'est une famille d'aide
président Repentin l'a évoqué on a ma
prime rénove aide nationale qui est
basée sur des forfaits des forfaits qui
sont particulièrement importants pour
les ménages les plus vulnérables et les
plus
de notre pays et qui sont évidemment
moins intéressants ou moins importants
en termes financiers que ceux qui sont
dédiés au ménage les plus aisés et puis
il y a ma prime rénove sérénité qui
permet de réaliser une rénovation
globale chez les ménages des 4 premiers
des cils de la population française et
ma prime rénov copropriété qui est une
aide destinée au syndicat de
copropriétaires qui est une aide
collective et qui s'adresse à tous les
propriétaires occupants et tous les
propriétaires bailleurs dont de ces
ensembles immobiliers donc lorsque l'on
parle de ma prime rénov lorsque l'on
énonce un certain nombre de chiffres en
fait il faut bien avoir en tête que on
est face à une gamme d'aide différente
et que évidemment les sujets ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes selon le type
d'aide sollicité et ce qui est très
important aussi à partager avec vous
c'est que ma prime rénovénientée et ma
prime rénov copropriété sont des aides à
la pierre donc des aides qui sont
délégués dans les territoires auprès je
préfère et qui sont contractualisés avec
les collectivités territoriales et donc
des aides qui sont décidés au niveau
local dans les politiques locales de
l'habitat et des aides qui sont donc
abondées par les collectivités
territoriales ce qui permet de réduire
le reste à charge des ménages qui sont
concernés par ces aides et bien sûr des
aides qui pour y accéder doivent
enfin oblige le ménage à être accompagné
j'y reviendrai donc on est déjà dans des
dispositifs d'accompagnement avec ce
tiers de confiance que qu'évoquait le
président Repentin qui permette
effectivement à ces ménages d'être
sécurisés donc voilà ce que ce que je
voulais rappeler et peut-être pour
revenir sur un certain nombre de
chiffres depuis 2020 donc quasiment 1,5
millions de ménages ont pu être financés
ce qui est considérable vous évoquez
monsieur le Président que l'activité de
l'agence a été multipliée par 10 son
budget a été multiplié par 5 mais
l'activité de l'agence a été multipliée
par 10 en l'espace d'un quinquennat cela
généré 6,2 milliards de primes financés
et générer 18,8 milliards d'euros de
travaux dans les logements ce qui est
aussi extrêmement important et en termes
de rénovation globale c'est 163000
logements qui ont pu bénéficier d'une
rénovation globale et qui ont pu être
financés sur la même période donc depuis
2020 et qui ont généré 1,8 milliards
d'euros de primes financés donc les
chiffres je ne conteste pas en fait au
travers de ce propos les chiffres de la
Cour des comptes mais la Cour des
comptes en fait a examiné dans son
rapport ma prime rénov nationale au
forfait et à regarder des bonus mais n'a
pas regardé l'ensemble de la famille des
aides c'est à dire l'aide nationale et
les aides à la pierre qui sont donc
contractualisés avec les collectivités
et donc il était important aussi de
revenir sur
cette vision globale à la fois sur cette
aide nationale et sur les aides à la
pierre et de bien partager avec vous que
lorsque l'on remet ces chiffres en
perspective on est de toute façon en
deçà de ce qui peut être attendu en
matière de rénovation globale en matière
de confort thermique dans les logements
complets en matière de moindre émission
de gaz à effet de serre voire de zéro
émission de gaz à effet de serre mais
pour autant le pourcentage et le volume
sont plus importants que ce qui on ne
regarde qu'une portion donc des données
des données de l'activité de l'agence
donc voilà sur sur ces questions de
rénovation énergétique et bien sûr je
pourrais détailler à l'aune de vos
questions en ce qui concerne France
Renov France rénov est un service public
qui a été introduit par la loi climat
résilience
et qui a été créé au 1er janvier dernier
donc il a il fait très bientôt son
premier anniversaire d'ici quelques
semaines bien sûr ce n'est pas un
service public nouveau au sens qui ne
que rien n'existait au préalable c'est
la Réunion en fait de deux réseaux
existants le réseau qui était piloté par
la dame qui est
qui existait sous le nom du réseau fer
et le réseau de Lana notamment des
équipes de suivi animation qui sont
pilotés par les maîtres d'ouvrage que
sont les collectivités territoriales et
qui sont co-financés donc par l'État et
les collectivités territoriales sur
l'ensemble des territoires donc c'est là
vraiment la réunion de ces deux réseaux
depuis le 1er janvier dernier avec des
financements je le rappelle à 50% par
l'état d'un côté de l'autre côté par les
collectivités territoriales et ce réseau
permet d'avoir des conseillé sur le
territoire qui sont des conseillers qui
ont des démarches proactives ou des
démarches de réponse en conseil en
information
des usagers qui souhaitent pouvoir
réaliser un diagnostic de leur logement
comprendre quels sont les mots maux de
ce logement les travaux qu'ils doivent
réaliser à l'intérieur de ce logement et
évidemment être conseillé le mieux
possible par rapport au parcours de
travaux qu'ils peuvent réaliser donc ce
réseau aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté il est piloté par la NA il
est animé par Lana nous avons nous
l'avons réuni dans sa totalité
de lors de la première quinzaine de du
mois de septembre dernier à Angers nous
avions plus de plus de 1 milliers de
personnes en salle et plus de 500
personnes connectées donc qui était très
attentif pendant deux jours d'ailleurs
au divers débats à la fois de politique
publique et des débats très techniques
aussi que nous avons pu avoir en atelier
avec eux et ce qui est important d'avoir
en tête c'est que c'est un réseau qui
augmente chaque année c'est à dire que
on a chaque année un nombre d'opérations
programmées d'amélioration qui augmente
un nombre de programmes d'intérêts
généraux qui augmentaient qui augmentent
également et évidemment un nombre
d'espaces conseils France rénov qui
augmente sur le territoire on est
aujourd'hui à plus de 450 espaces
conseils France rénov et environ 2100
conseillers sur l'ensemble du territoire
national ce sont des derrière ces
derrière ces chiffres ce sont des
individus ce sont des conseillers
essentiellement en amélioration de
l'habitat et en rénovation énergétique
qui sont plutôt des techniciens et qui
évidemment ont un objectif
quotidien c'est de d'orienter le ménage
dans le meilleur parcours de travaux
mais comme le disait le Président il y a
quelques minutes chaque ménage n'est pas
prêt à s'engager dans une rénovation
globale une rénovation globale enfin moi
je vais je vais vous le dire comme je le
dis systématiquement personne ni dans
cette salle ni ailleurs je crois mais
s'il y a s'il y a s'il y a une exception
à la règle
échangeant à ce sujet mais personne ne
se lève le matin en ayant envie de faire
des travaux chez soi faire des travaux
chez soi c'est intrusif ça ça provoque
toutes sortes de difficultés
on ne sait pas quand c'est fini
effectivement j'y reviendrai c'est la
question de l'émiments des filières et
des corps d'état est un sujet mais
personne n'a envie de faire des travaux
chez soi donc le tiers de confiance
je le tiers de confiance est
effectivement très important pour
sécuriser le ménage pour sécuriser le
ménage par rapport à l'offre de travaux
qui lui est fait par les entreprises
mais aussi pour s'assurer que les
travaux qu'il va réaliser sont sont de
seront de qualité et qu'il n'aura pas
forcément besoin d'y revenir mais il y a
des ménages qui de toute façon ne sont
engageront pas dans une démarche de
travaux global immédiatement et à qui il
faut pouvoir proposer un parcours de
travaux par étape et ceux qui ont se
sont engagés
ceux qui se sont engagés dans ce
parcours de travaux sont
des personnes vers lesquelles ces
conseillers France rénov que j'évoquais
doivent pouvoir revenir pour leur
permettre d'aller dans l'étape suivante
donc ce point est extrêmement important
mais en tout cas sur le pilotage du
réseau France rénov et sur l'animation
de ce réseau je vous confirme que Lana
est bien en charge de ce réseau et que
sur les modalités de financement ce
réseau reste Co c'est d'un côté par la
LinkedIn générique budgétaire de
l'agence c'est-à-dire les financements
des opas et des programmes d'intérêt
généraux et de l'autre côté par le
programme SAR porté par l'ADEME même si
nous assurons aujourd'hui le pilotage
global de cet ensemble ensuite sur
l'accélération de la rénovation globale
en fait j'ai déjà posé quelques quelques
éléments
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs ingrédients si vous
permettez de le formulaire ainsi il y a
bien sûr les aides publiques et le
président l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
le sujet de ma prime rénove est une aide
effectivement
différente suivant suivant le type de
ménage et suivant évidemment la démarche
de travaux dans laquelle il a envie de
s'engager
cette aide nous espérons effectivement
au conseil d'administration pouvoir
prendre en compte pour l'année 2023 les
effets de l'inflation de façon à ce que
effectivement les les difficultés
rencontrées par les ménages et les
entreprises aussi sur sur les
territoires puissent être prendre en
compte prise en compte dans ce dans
cette dans cette
dans cette solvabilité des ménages le
deuxième élément fondamental c'est la
politique locale c'est le portage
politique une politique d'amélioration
de l'habitat privé de rénovation
énergétique de l'habitat privé
nécessite
une proximité avec les usagers et un
portage politique très fort on voit bien
dans le distinguo des opérations
programmées d'amélioration de l'habitat
qu'il y en a qui sont extrêmement
productives avec des objectifs ambitieux
qui sont atteints au bout de la durée de
ces opérations et d'autres opérations
qui sont plus difficiles tout dépend
évidemment des moyens qui sont mis et du
portage qui est opéré la réussite dépend
aussi de la qualité des opérateurs les
opérateurs sont évidemment les
accompagnateurs mais on sait qu'on est
face à des publics très différents à des
structures très différentes
au plan juridique bien entendu mais
surtout des profils en fait de
professionnels différents on sait qu'on
a des territoires qui attirent plus ou
moins ces structures soient associatives
soit privée donc évidemment le sujet est
variable et puis enfin la question des
entreprises la question du Réseau des
entreprises évidemment de la densité
d'existence sur certains territoires ou
du manque parfois sur d'autres de leur
carnet de commandes qui sont très
complets du peut-être manque de main
d'oeuvre dans certains champs et puis
enfin de la question de l'émettement on
a aujourd'hui un réseau d'entreprise
générale qui est très
performant très existant sur pour
réaliser des travaux de grande ampleur
notamment dans le champ du logement
social en revanche dans le champ du parc
privé face à des particuliers dans leur
appartement ou dans leur maison
individuelle ils sont face en fait à des
réseaux de corps d'état séparés qui ne
sont pas forcément organisés pour
pouvoir réaliser des travaux globaux et
donc une opération complète
d'amélioration du logement et notamment
de sa performance thermique et puis
enfin la question de l'innovation dans
l'industrie notamment en matière
d'isolation d'isolation par l'extérieur
d'isolation par l'intérieur pour des
travaux plus rapides moins invasif moins
complexe ça restera invasif je ne crois
pas à la baguette magique en matière de
travaux dans le logement en milieu
occupé mais pour autant on a su faire
d'énormes avancées sur certains champs
techniques en matière de bâtiment et
dans ce domaine-là beaucoup de choses
sont réfléchies et sont en cours de de
propositions mais pour autant il faut
des produits évidemment qui peuvent être
mis en oeuvre de façon la plus rapide
possible et qui sont efficaces et qui
bien sûr sont accessibles à tous
voilà ce que je pouvais partager avec
vous pardon d'avoir été peut-être un peu
longue mais le sujet vous l'avez vous
l'avez pointé et riche et complexe merci
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur le
Madame la Directrice Générale
pardonnez-moi je vous donne voilà
merci monsieur le Président vous êtes
fort nombreux à avoir des questions donc
je vais d'abord donner la parole à
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne puis à Daniel
crémilia je vous le montrerai de
répondre et ensuite on prendra
l'ensemble des questions et je
demanderai à mes collègues évidemment
d'être précis et concis comme d'habitude
et non redondant voilà Dominique merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice générale
je voudrais bien sûr revenir sur
certains sujets que vous avez déjà
évoqué dans vos propos soit pour les
préciser et les compléter est-ce que la
NA va véritablement bouger les curseurs
pour mieux accompagner les ménages alors
vous l'avez dit tous les deux et on en
est tous conscients aujourd'hui une ré
globale elle n'est pas nécessairement
mieux aidé par ma prime rénove que des
gestes uniques est-ce que cela va
changer donc vous avez parlé d'une
révision de la de la hausse des plafonds
de travaux vous avez parlé aussi de
l'adaptation à l'inflation que connaît
notre notre pays est-ce que c'est
curseurs vont véritablement bouger et
surtout dans les copropriétés comment
allez-vous accélérer même si vous avez
donné des chiffres qui sont en
progression de ma prime rénov copro
depuis 2020 jusqu'à l'année 2022
allez-vous doubler les aides pour les
copropriétaires modestes comme c'est
envisagé et surtout comment comptez-vous
mieux mobiliser les syndics les syndics
qu'ils ont un rôle central à jouer
auprès des copropriétaires et on voit
encore que les syndics sont peu
impliqués sur la question de la
rénovation globale quand on interroge
des copropriétaires une grande partie
d'entre eux disent qu'ils ont été peu
sens par les syndics sur la rénovation
globale comment comptez-vous les
mobiliser est-ce que cela passe par la
formation des professionnels voilà donc
pour la première question ensuite je
crois que le président repentant a parlé
du DPE avant et après les travaux mais
est-ce que pour autant vous allez le
rendre obligatoire se DPE aujourd'hui
c'est assez rare et on a beaucoup de mal
à mesurer vous l'avez dit les gains qui
sont
engrangés en termes de gaz à effet de
serre et de sortie surtout de passoire
thermique ce qui provoque de nombreuses
critiques mais les diagnostiquers
sont-ils aujourd'hui à même de répondre
à la demande et Lana peut-elle le
financer enfin on dit souvent que le
guichet unique c'est en fait un guichet
de plus je voudrais que vous nous
expliquiez comment le nouveau numéro de
téléphone d'information ainsi que la
plateforme digitale France
avec les différents réseaux de services
d'information qui existaient avant
d'être rassemblés dans le réseau France
rénov enfin est-il prévu de modifier
l'organisation actuelle du réseau pour
assurer une couverture qui soit plus
homogène sur l'ensemble du territoire un
partenariat avec les maisons France
service est-il envisagé et dernière
question vous n'y avez pas fait
référence quid de ma prime adapte qui
est donc une aide à l'adaptation des
logements au vieillissement de la
population
tant sur l'éligibilité de cette prime a
primadapte que sur son financement merci
merci Dominique Daniel Gremillet
oui merci Madame un présidente monsieur
le Président Madame la Directrice
Générale mes chers collègues dans le
cadre de mes travaux budgétaires sur les
crédits énergie du PNF pour 2023 je me
suis félicité de la matification de ma
prime rénove tout en relevant c'est
limite et j'en retiens deux et je
prolonge ce que vient de dire ma
collègue Dominique Estrosi ça sonne la
première limite concerne ces conditions
d'éligibilité il me semble que l'accès à
la prime des propriétaires bailleurs et
des syndicats de copropriété doit encore
progresser en 2021 3619 propriétaires
bailleurs ont persuades soit 0,95% du
total des versements et 162
copropriétaires l'ont demandé soit 0,02%
du total des demandes de plus l'accès la
prime des ménages intermédiaires et
supérieurs et qu'il s'achève cette fin
d'année doit être prorogée nous l'avons
proposé dans le cadre des lois de
finances initiales et rectificatives
mais cela doit être traduit
réglementairement comment l'ANA
compte-t-elle progresser dans le sens
d'une plus d'universalité dans la
poussée de la prime la seconde limite
porte sur le montant du reste à charge
les équipements éligibles et forfaits
prévus étant et limitées le montant
moyen de la prime et de 30003 euros en
2020 comment garantir dans ce contexte
en accompagnement suffisamment attractif
pour les ménages peut-on encore
améliorer l'articulation entre la prime
et les autres dispositifs de soutien
budgétaire ou extra budgétaire existants
je pense notamment au C2E dont les
montants sont élevés et le coût
budgétaire nul mais qui constitue un
vrai maquis pour les ménages ne
pourrait-on pas renforcer l'information
délivrée par le réseau France rénov à ce
sujet merci
monsieur le Président ou Madame la
Directrice générale je fais qui de vous
deux réponds
d'accord très bien alors je vais je vais
prendre les questions dans dans l'ordre
peut-être en précisant comme le disait
le président tout à l'heure que notre
conseil d'administration qui prendra un
certain nombre de décisions se tient la
semaine prochaine enfin celui sur les
délibérations techniques et sur le
budget initial 2023 donc il est
difficile ce matin de pouvoir vous
assurer de évidemment de du résultat de
de ce vote de ce de ces votes de la
semaine prochaine en revanche ce que
l'on peut partager avec vous c'est que
oui Lana travaille avec ses tutelles ces
tutelle technique donc ministère du
Logement et évidemment ministère en
charge des questions d'énergie sur
l'évolution de ces aides c'était le sens
je pense de nos propos introductifs en
faveur bien entendu de la rénovation
globale et c'est donc c'est un enfin je
vais vous le dire de cette manière là le
c'est un travail de longue haleine c'est
à dire que on a une première étape 2023
qui est une réponse aux questions
d'inflation et puis on travaille sur des
évolutions plus substantielles de
rééquilibrage de convergence comme
celles qu'on a déjà pu réaliser la
première étape de convergence était bien
sûr de transformer un crédit d'impôt
en une aide directe avec une évidemment
une orientation sociale très importante
on a aussi fait convergé déjà beaucoup
de critères mais on a encore des étapes
à franchir et c'est tous les travaux qui
bien sûr vont nous animer comme je vous
le disais avec nos tutelles à compter de
l'année prochaine et en fait qui nous
qui nous anime déjà pour améliorer la
rénovation globale en copropriété vous
avez si vous permettez à la fois poser
la question et présenter un élément de
réponse effectivement les syndics enfin
en fait on a un duo on a un duo syndic
maître d'oeuvre architecte qui est
fondamental il se trouve que que j'étais
avec le ministre de la Ville et du
logement dans le sud dans le sud de la
Seine la semaine dernière nous avons
visité une copropriété qui a fait qui a
fait une rénovation globale
en 80 lots en trois édifices qui a fait
une rénovation globale sur les deux
années les échafaudages avaient été
retirés une semaine avant la visite et
une rénovation globale donc complète sur
trois trois ensembles immobiliers 80
logements la chose était claire les
aides ont été évidemment très enfin
rapporté beaucoup de satisfaction
évidemment aux copropriétaires mais il y
avait quelque chose de très lisible dans
les échanges de cette matinée
premièrement un président de conseil
syndical extrêmement impliqué dans la
démarche un syndic extrêmement impliqué
également et un maître d'oeuvre un
architecte extrêmement impliqué aussi
ils ont ils ont constitué un trio qui a
permis pendant deux ans d'obtenir le
vote en assemblée générale de convaincre
et ensuite bien entendu de suivre les
travaux mais moi j'ai bien compris que
la première année de conviction avait
été finalement l'année presque la plus
complexe et la plus dense en énergie
développée par ces trois par ces trois
acteurs donc du coup effectivement la
formation l'implication des syndics est
extrêmement importante après ce que je
peux partager avec vous c'est que bien
sûr on a un axe de formation et
d'échange avec eux mais que j'étais hier
au congrès de la fnaïm et que pour la
première fois parce que bon j'y vais pas
j'y vais pas systématiquement mais en
tout cas pour la première fois depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années
la salle était comble sur les sujets
rénovation énergétiques et sur les
échanges qu'on a pu avoir à la fois avec
la présidence de la fenaïm mais aussi
avec la FFB qui était présente avec
Saint-Gobain qui était présent aussi et
aussi avec des représentants de de
structures qui accompagnent les ménages
et que les syndics posent de plus en
plus de questions sur ces sujets donc on
a un axe de formation très important et
puis bien sûr l'évolution des aides que
vous avez évoquées fait partie des
discussions de la semaine prochaine dont
nous espérons effectivement en première
étape je le dis bien en première étape
obtenir effectivement des votes
favorables
sur le diagnostic de performance
énergétique en fait c'est la question de
l'évaluation avant travaux et après
travaux donc sur ma prime rénov
copropriété sur ma prime rénov sérénité
c'est déjà une obligation puisqu'on
mesure le gain énergétique c'est le
diagnostic enfin c'est ce qu'on appelle
un audit en fait et aujourd'hui nous
travaillons donc sur la convergence
évidemment de cette audit avec le
diagnostic de performance énergétique et
effectivement dans nos travaux à venir
l'implication ou plutôt l'implémentation
et l'obligation de ce diagnostic
préalable et de ce diagnostic final
effectivement fait partie des pistes de
réflexion c'est le moyen effectivement
de s'assurer qu'on a un gain énergétique
un gain énergétique mesuré dans chaque
logement en sachant que les chiffres que
l'on a aujourd'hui sur ma prime rénov
nationale sont des chiffres de mesure
conventionnelles et donc il faut qu'on
puisse effectivement avoir quelque chose
de plus précis et de plus et qui
s'inscrit dans la réalité pour pour
autant je partage avec vous qu'à partir
du moment où évidemment on inscrira ou
s'inscrirait je préfère le dire aux
conditionnel cette obligation le
parcours du ménage devient évidemment
plus complexe parce que il aura
évidemment des pièces supplémentaires et
un acte supplémentaire à réaliser mais
l'accompagnement devrait évidemment
l'aider dans ce parcours
sur France rénov comment se fait
l'articulation donc la plateforme France
rénov effectivement
s'appuie sa dose sur une plateforme
numérique qui a été créée au 1er janvier
dernier et à partir de cette plateforme
soit en prise de contact téléphonique
soit évidemment en
accès numérique sur cette plateforme on
est dirigé immédiatement vers les
structures locales immédiatement vers
les structures locales c'est-à-dire
qu'il suffit sur la plateforme de
rentrer son adresse pour être mis en
contact en fait avec enfin on obtient
l'adresse et le numéro de téléphone du
réseau le plus proche de chez de chez
soi et lorsqu'on téléphone on est mis en
contact directement avec le réseau le
réseau local et une convention est en
cours de préparation avec l'Agence
nationale de cohésion des territoires
pour effectivement faire le lien avec
les maisons France service alors ça
existe déjà en fait dans certains
territoires il y a déjà des permanences
rénove dans les maisons France services
mais par contre ce n'est pas sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
l'objectif c'est évidemment de le
généraliser mais on a des territoires
qui n'ont pas attendu une convention de
niveau national pour le faire et
l'objectif aussi c'est d'impliquer les
maisons françaises pour un certain
nombre d'usagers qui sont éloignés du
numérique et qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement pour pouvoir accéder à
ces plateformes et faire leur demande je
continue sur les questions de rénovation
énergétique sur les limites de ma prime
rénove notamment pour les propriétaires
bailleurs
un gros travail alors pour les
propriétaires bailleurs je vais je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui existe déjà
en fait il y a trois aides il y a deux
aides qui sont des aides aux travaux il
y a ma prime rénov propriétaire bailleur
et il y a habité mieux sérénité
propriétaire bailleur qui leur
permettent de réaliser des travaux
massifs dans leur logement et ce que
l'on constate au travers des
financements de la nasse et que les
propriétaires bailleurs qui s'engagent
dans ce type de ce type de démarche
réalisent des travaux d'ampleur c'est à
dire en moyenne le bouquet de travaux
est aux alentours de 50000 euros voire
il peut monter jusqu'à 60000 euros de
montant de travaux ce qui s'orientent
plutôt vers ma prime rénov ma prime
rénove sont des propriétaires qui sont
plutôt propriétaires bailleurs qui font
un changement d'équipement à un moment
donné et uniquement un changement
d'équipement et là on est sur des
montants de travaux effectivement qui
sont plus qui sont plus modestes
ce que l'on constate et vous l'avez
effectivement pointé au travers des
chiffres c'est qu'on a peu de
propriétaires bailleurs qui s'oriente
quand même vers ces demandes de travaux
enfin ces demandes d'aide pour pouvoir
réaliser des travaux et la question
reste pleine et entière notamment
contenu des des contraintes qui
s'imposent aux propriétaires ailleurs au
travers de la loi climat résilience et
donc on va travailler dans les dans les
prochains mois à une convergence
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte finalement
il n'y ait qu'un seul peut-être
dispositif pour leur permettre de pour
leur permettre finalement de d'avoir une
aide la plus simple possible pour
pouvoir réaliser ses travaux et puis
ensuite on a une l'aide une aide fiscale
qui est Locke avantage qui là continue
enfin en tout cas les chiffres qu'on
sortira début 2022 montreront que on est
toujours sur une tendance plutôt
haussière mais modestement c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas une envolée de
sollicitations de sa tête fixa fiscale
mais pour autant on n'est pas non plus
on n'est pas dans la continuité on voit
que de plus en plus de propriétaires
bailleurs la sollicitent mais pas de
façon massive et en tout cas pas de
façon suffisante pour pouvoir réellement
traiter l'ensemble du parc et sur la
question du reste à charge effectivement
le montant moyen de l'aide ma prime
rénov est aux alentours de 3000 euros
sur ma prime rénove nationale parce
qu'on est sur un changement d'équipement
et qu'on moyenne évidemment les aides
aux propriétaires les plus les plus
les plus
aisées voilà et ceux qui évidemment sont
les plus vulnérables ce que l'on
constate c'est que quand même les les
forfaits qui sont sollicités concernent
des équipements des carbonés donc pompe
à chaleur chaudière à granulés poêle à
granulés donc de plus en plus alors que
au moment où ma prime rénov a été créée
on avait beaucoup de demandes en
chaudière gaz même THPE mais aujourd'hui
vraiment il y a voilà il y a vraiment
mais mais l'inflexion s'est fait dès
2021 donc voilà 2020 on était encore
beaucoup dans cette tendance chaudière
gaz et HPE et puis à partir de l'année
2021 le forfaits les forfaits des cartes
d'équipements des carbonés ont été très
sollicités et sur les C2E
c'est ce que le président évoquait tout
à l'heure
ils ont enfin les ménages d'une manière
générale sollicitent les c2eux quand il
sollicite ma prime rénove quasiment
systématiquement mais au travers des
entreprises au travers des entreprises
en tout cas dans les déclarations qu'ils
nous font sur la plateforme on voit bien
que c'est ces deux œufs sont sollicités
simplement les critères enfin le
principe de convergence des critères et
de sollicitations de ces C2E doit être
amélioré mais laisser deux œufs comme
vous l'avez dit c'est c'est une aide en
fait au fond entre guillemets privés et
pas une aide publique et c'est toute la
complexité des travaux qui sont devant
nous
et ma primadap alors ma frimada pardon
je suis longue mais les questions sont
très riches ma Primada donc
effectivement le gouvernement a annoncé
cette nouvelle aide pour normalement
début d'année 2024 donc nous y
travaillons nous y travaillons dans un
registre évidemment de création d'une
nouvelle aide je le rappelle l'objectif
c'est de fusionner l'aide qui existe
déjà côté Anna qui s'appelle habiter
facile le crédit d'impôt et les aides de
la CNAV donc et d'avoir grâce à cette se
rapprochement et cette fusion de trois
aides d'avoir une seule aide existante
donc plus simple plus simple à capter et
par ailleurs évidemment avec
une augmentation du plafond de travaux
et une augmentation de l'aide par
ailleurs en terme de périmètre c'est une
aide qui sera des qui sera
destiné pardon au ménage les plus
modestes donc les quatre premiers des
cils de la population française ménage
en situation de perte d'autonomie soit
en raison de de leur âge soit en raison
d'un handicap et la l'objectif je crois
que le ministre l'a dit au moment d'un
colloque au mois d'octobre et que ma
Primada soit une aide à la pierre
rapidement revenir sur deux points sur
la question des syndics qui est une
question très importante dans l'acte de
décision
la réussite d'une politique publique
c'est les moyens qui sont mis par la
nation les collectivités territoriales
mais sur ce sujet là on est sur des
décisions vous l'avez bien compris
d'individus seul dans leur maison ou
d'individus agrégés dans une copropriété
je j'ai assisté comme Elie locale
vice-président chargé de l'habitation
mon territoire à plusieurs assemblées
générales de copropriété au cours des
derniers mois pour des actes de décision
de s'engager ou non très franchement
j'ai trouvé que l'ambiance est bien plus
difficile que qu'une campagne électorale
si je peux faire
une comparaison c'est une très grande
violence
ressortent dans ces discussions les
problèmes de voisinage
des stratégies qui sont assez
différentes au sein d'une copropriété
entre un propriétaire occupant un
propriétaire bailleur propriétaire
multibailleur qui a une stratégie
patrimoniale dans beaucoup de
immeuble de votre de votre ville et je
ne sais pas si certaines ou certains ont
eu la chance de voir un film qui est
sorti il y a quelques mois sur les
grands écrans que s'appelait les
promesses de l'histoire d'une mère d'une
ville de banlieue jouée par Madame
Isabelle Huppert qui est confronté à un
problème d'une copropriété ce film est
admirable pour voir quels sont les
stratégies au sein d'une copropriété et
comment la puissance publique se heurte
à une non décision et Madame stratiazone
c'est vous qui avez posé la question
c'est vrai que
c'est la différence entre le logement
public et le logement privé car au
moment où la loi climat est résilience a
été adoptée le parc public consomme 30%
d'énergie de moins que le parc privé 50%
d'eau de moins que le parc privé parce
que vous avez des stratégies d'entretien
du patrimoine et à s'indique qui en
l'occurrence le directeur de l'organisme
HLM avec des représentants de locataires
qui ont un rôle de sensibilisation
parfois des collectivités territoriales
derrière c'est pour cela que la question
des syndics est très importante et que
on voit sur le territoire des réunions
aussi qui sont organisées par les EPCI à
destination des syndics pour les former
à cette question de la sensibilisation
sur la donnée environnementale voilà
donc c'est un vrai vrai travail le
représentant des syndics qui siègent au
conseil d'administration de l'ANAH nous
dit que la durée moyenne entre
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour du
dossier de rénovation et la réalisation
c'est 6 ans et demi
dans une copropriété privée voilà c'est
un vrai sujet qui peut aussi expliquer
pourquoi dans une politique même s'il y
a des moyens il peut y avoir une prise
de décision bien plus difficile qu'on ne
l'imaginent alors des textes sur
l'obligation de faire des travaux sinon
vous pouvez pas louer augmenter les
loyers etc vont sans doute aider à la
prise de décision mais et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura on a l'espoir de voir une
croissance assez forte dans les années
qui viennent parce que il y a ces
obligations réglementaires et que
certains propriétaires bailleurs vont
aussi se dire mince je peux plus louer
je peux plus changer le loyer ça va sans
doute nous aider mais les assemblées
générales sont vraiment très très
difficiles la dernière chose c'est un
complément sur
France rénov le tiers de confiance c'est
vraiment très important
il y a des gens qui viennent qui
poussent la porte ils savent pas ce
qu'il faut faire et donc ils vont avoir
en phase 2 quelqu'un qui vont leur dire
bah écoutez nous on a besoin de quoi
faut que nous ameniez si possible si
vous les avez les plantes construction
de votre habitation quel est
l'orientation de votre habitation en
quelle année elle a été faite puisque
les normes thermiques de la décennie 70
n'est pas le même que les années 80
qu'avez-vous fait vous-même quel est le
vitrage de ce que c'est du simple
vitrage double vitrage et des gens
viennent sans aucune idée préconçue sauf
qu'ils savent que ils vont s'engager de
sur les travaux qui peuvent être
effectivement très perturbants pour leur
vie quotidienne et puis vous avez une
partie qui ont travaillé qui se disent
voilà nous on va faire ça faut que les
ménages qui viennent avec un projet tout
fait la moitié change le projet la
moitié change le projet lorsqu'ils ont
vu le conseiller France Renov
parce que ils ont eu un conseil ou des
idées préconçues
ont été remises en cause la priorité
c'est le changement du vitrage bah non
c'est plutôt l'isolation du toit
des murs et ensuite voilà donc c'est
très important qu'il puisse venir en se
disant je vais avoir un conseil sans que
derrière il y a un intérêt de celui qui
me qui me conseille faites l'expérience
si vous pouvez vous-même alors c'est
quand on est sénateur c'est difficile
parce qu'on est clairement identifié moi
je les fais à titre personnel voilà en
allant poser un projet et vous revenez
effectivement
avec une réflexion qui est pas la même
c'est important qu'on puisse nous
assurer quand on pousse la porte de
France rénov on est ce conseil qui
puisse éclairer utilement chaque dossier
est un cas particulier je vous assure
chaque dossier voilà donc c'est
important je voulais simplement vous le
redire c'est que c'est aussi notre leur
demande d'explication la plus pertinente
pour celles et ceux qui viennent nous
voir merci monsieur le Président alors
j'ai demandé à mes collègues d'être
concis dans leur question puisque vous
êtes encore 17 à devoir poser des
questions Olivier Ritman ensuite Laurent
saumon oui merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président et Madame
l'annéehatrie générale je vais vous
parler d'un sujet qui remonte
régulièrement au niveau de la présidente
et je remercie vraiment madame la
Présidente d'avoir organisé cette cette
audition parce qu'on est un certain
nombre et je trouve que vous avez parlé
du sujet mais de manière plutôt
superficielle alors que c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui qui pourrit la vie de
certains de nos concitoyens qui ont
monté des dossiers ma prime rénov et qui
aujourd'hui n'y voit pas d'issue au bout
de six mois au bout d'un an au bout d'un
an et demi alors que des dépenses ont
été engagés il y a la même qui se
retrouvent dans des situations hors de
réaliser des prêts bancaires pour payer
des travaux et quelquefois uniquement
par un manque de communication vous
l'avez dit Madame la Directrice
aujourd'hui on met en place et on fait
en sorte que sur les territoires y ait
des interlocuteurs notamment ma prime
rénove territorialisée et on se rend
compte d'une chose c'est qu'à la fois on
a une plateforme nationale qui traite
les dossiers à la fois on a des
interlocuteurs territoriaux mais il y a
pas de communication dans les deux sens
entre les deux et du rapport même de la
veuve même du directeur de la DDT de la
Haute-Saône cette semaine il me dit nous
on peut faire remonter les choses mais
on n'a aucune vision sur les dossiers
leur instruction où ça en est et on n'a
pas de descente et la même chose pour
les les conseillers France rénov
territoriaux et on a moi j'ai sous les
yeux des dossiers qui datent depuis un
an sur des petits détails et on se rend
compte que ma prime rénove c'est vrai
c'est quelque chose de très important
qui nous permettra d'arriver à des
objectifs écologiques environnementaux
dans les 20 ans qui viennent mais qui
suffit d'un petit grain de sable pour
que la vie de nos concitoyens soit
complètement pourri alors j'aimerais
qu'on ait des interlocuteurs
d'ailleurs ce ce sujet a été montré du
doigt par la Défenseur des droits dans
un communiqué de presse qui date de fin
octobre et qui part d'hyper des
matérialisation et d'hypers
centralisation où on en est dans la
volonté de régler ses problèmes et nous
en tant que sénateur on est
régulièrement sollicité par nos
concitoyens vers qui devons-nous nous
adresser pour avoir enfin des réponses
et déverrouiller ces dossiers sur
lesquels on ne voit pas d'issue merci
beaucoup Olivier Laurence saumon ensuite
Viviane Martigues
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice Générale effectivement ça va
revenir un petit peu sur ce qui vient
d'être dit mais à propos en particulier
du du logement insalubre
parce que vous avez parlé effectivement
que l'intérêt de cette politique c'était
la massification et vous avez également
dit effectivement que c'était il y avait
des spécifices individuels et qu'il
fallait accompagner chaque Français et
c'est véritablement le cas que vient
d'évoquer Olivia Ritman et que je veux
aussi vous poser parce que de la
nécessité au projet du projet au concret
et bien c'est un parcours du combattant
les délais de difficultés vous avez dit
la maîtrise d'oeuvre d'une part et de la
sollicitation et de la mobilisation des
entreprises sans qu'elle soit des des
comment dire des marchands de sommeil et
qu'il faut donc bien les labelliser
est-ce qu'il y a une proposition qui est
faite en ce sens sur la labilisation des
entreprises sur la possibilité d'avoir
comme le propose par exemple lors des
architectes donc une maîtrise d'ouvrage
qui soit proposée aux EPCI pour pouvoir
les accompagner et puis un point qui a
été oublié comme important et dont
Olivier Rickman vient de pointer c'est
les avances les régies d'avance il y a
bien sûr des collectivités des EPCI qui
s'y sont engagés personnellement va s'y
engager au niveau du conseil
départemental de mon département mais on
voit bien qu'il y a une difficulté pour
engager les financements et donc ça
montre bien que ce parcours est
extrêmement compliqué quoi qu'en dit je
dirais les propos très enthousiasmants
que vous avez pu nous tenir
de vous donner un exemple qui dure
depuis deux ans et demi qui est
absolument innommable
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président vous avez dit dans les
derniers de Lana que les 80 % des
logements de 2005 ans existe déjà
effectivement j'en vois bien que c'est
pour
montrer l'importance de la rénovation
simplement bon on est on se dit aussi
que c'est peut-être aussi pour justifier
la panne dans la construction de
logements que nous avons actuellement
est-ce que vous pensez réellement que le
rythme de construction actuel
suffira pour répondre aux besoins de
logement abordable et des 2,2 millions
de personnes qui attendent un logement
social et qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
du dispositif second de vie de faire du
neuf dans dans l'ancien qui pourrait
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on pense sur la
question de la rénovation
on voit bien que les financements sont
là et vous l'avez bien montré que la
difficulté plutôt plus de vers la
arguments et vers la filière aussi qui
est très atomisée sur la question de
l'accompagnement est-ce que vous pensez
parce que cet accompagnement il est
particulièrement difficile sur la
rénovation qui est très importante en
milieu rural dans les logements
améliorural est-ce que vous avez des
dispositifs dans vos structures locales
pour aller vers les habitants et
dernière chose sur la question de de ça
a été évoqué de ce qui pourrait exister
par rapport à la filière l'organisation
de la filière est-ce que il faudrait pas
mettre un autre ministère dans le Lot
celui de l'économie avec l'artisanat et
l'industrie
merci Viviane Amel gacquet ensuite
Jean-Claude Tissot madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice vous l'avez dit vous devrez
aujourd'hui dans un contexte qui vous
confère un rôle essentiel explosion des
coûts de l'énergie baisse du pouvoir
d'achat des règlements climatiques et
vous êtes
identifié aujourd'hui comme un acteur
majeur en matière de rénovation
l'augmentation des demandes notamment
une multiplication par 1050 en atteste
et c'est dans ce cadre que je vous
interpelle il a été évoqué des
dysfonctionnements dans la gestion des
dossiers de ma prime rénov mais je
souhaite évoquer la situation de nos
concitoyens qui ne peuvent pas déposer
de dossiers qui ne poussent pas
forcément la porte des guichets
d'information en effet la
dématérialisation complète de la
procédure nécessite une connexion
Internet nous savons que près de 13
millions des Français souffrent
d'électronisme ces Français sont aussi
souvent les plus modestes et les plus à
même de vous solliciter vous avez évoqué
Madame la Directrice brièvement
brièvement le sujet et compte tenu de
l'enjeu j'aimerais creuser en fait ce
sujet comment comptez-vous aujourd'hui
pallier à ce dysfonctionnement vous
adressez à ce public démuni face à
l'usage d'Internet est-ce qu'une action
particulière est prévue je vous remercie
merci
so ensuite Rémi Cardo merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice générale pour ma part je
souhaiterais revenir sur la question
spécifique de la rénovation thermique de
logements situés en zone rurale avec
près de 936 000 habitations concernées
soit un taux de 22% de ces territoires
pour ces territoires ruraux contre une
moyenne nationale fixée à 19,6%. à
l'exception de l'agglomération
parisienne ou taux est le plus élevé les
espaces ruraux sont donc légèrement
moins bien nautiques les logements dans
les plus grandes agglos l'explication
apportée est souvent l'ancienneté
attribuée aux constructions dans les
zones rurales ce qui n'est pas ce qui
n'est pourtant pas forcément le cas si
on établit une comparaison avec les
bâtiments urbains ainsi je souhaitais
connaître votre analyse les difficultés
rencontrées même si vous avez abordé
sujet là tout à l'heure pas la
rénovation thermique dans ces
territoires le dispositif m'a prime
rénove souvent mise en avant comme une
grande réussite par le gouvernement
connaît pourtant de nombreuses
problématiques plusieurs collègues les
ont soulignés et ne semble pas répondre
à tous les enjeux et ce que vient de
souligner ma collègue daker est très
pourtant en termes de connexion et de
capacité à utiliser le les le numérique
pensez-vous qu'une adaptation de ce
dispositif pour les territoires ruraux
pourrait être pertinents ou considérer
vous que d'autres politiques publiques
pourraient être plus efficaces merci
si Jean-Claude Rémy Cardon ensuite
Françoise merci madame la Présidente ma
question effectivement
revenir tout simplement sur le rapport
du CESU qui dit en 2021 la rénovation
globale concernait moins de 1000
dossiers soit
0,2% des demandes financées en 2021 avec
un montant moyen de 3000 euros ça a été
dit tout à l'heure par mes collègues
mais vous dire aussi que en parallèle
effectivement ça 14% des ménages
français sont en situation de précarité
énergétique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand je vous entends dire
personne n'a envie de faire des travaux
chez soi vu l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité du gaz et vu le reste à
charge aussi qui est près de 40% pour
les plus modestes et ça c'est plusieurs
rapports qui le stipulent effectivement
il va falloir aussi mettre la main à la
pâte et accélérer et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vais vous poser
plusieurs questions
pensez-vous qu'il faille opérer une
simplification des dispositifs d'aide à
la rénovation thermique en essayant de
les conditions d'accès
pensez-vous qu'un reste à charge
zéro à destination des propriétaires
modestes seraient une solution pour
accélérer la rénovation thermique des
logements et tout simplement aussi faire
un focus
pour justement stopper je dirais les
l'effet des rénovations monogestes
est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à soit
absorber ou supprimer ma prime rénov au
profit de ma prime
rénove sérénité je comprends que c'est
une porte d'entrée pour certains pour en
tout cas certains ménages mais dans ce
cas là faut-il clairement l'assumer que
c'est une porte d'entrée pour les
embarquer sur une une rénovation globale
et donc mettre des dispositions
incitatives pour les faire basculer sur
ma prime rénov sérénité alors est-ce que
c'est dans en tout cas dans votre
feuille de route et puis j'ajouterai
aussi une remarque sur la situation de
ce qu'on entend sur le terrain notamment
sur les obligations les interdictions
qui pèsent sur les propriétaires dans
les dans café mais bien évidemment ça ne
s'applique pas
à de nombreuses personnes parce que par
exemple l'interdiction d'augmentation de
loyer ne s'applique pas un bail signé
avant le 24 août 2022 de même
l'interdiction de location ne
s'appliquera pas pour les logements les
plus consommateurs au premier janvier si
le bail a été signé avant le 24 août
donc ce qui est gênant là-dedans c'est
que comment un locataire
dans le rapport de force entre le
propriétaire et le locataire comment un
locataire peut inciter son propriétaire
à à ne pas réviser le loyer parce qu'il
y ait des augmentations de loyer et
pourtant il est déclaré pas de soi
thermique depuis bien longtemps mais
sauf que son bail a été signé aussi
depuis bien longtemps donc là dessus je
trouve qu'il y a un rapport de force qui
est pas sain faut-il aller jusqu'à une
révision de loyer autorisée si et
seulement si le une mise à jour du DPE
enfin voilà je c'est un peu complexe
mais je je vous invite à y regarder
quand même
très bien merci Rémi Françoise Ferrat
ensuite Marie-Christine Chauvin oui
merci madame le Président de Monsieur
serait très rapide puisque ma question
rejoint celle de notre collègue
Dominique Estrosi Sassone et concernait
les divers plafonds et ça me semble me
supposant un point fondamental mais je
voudrais profiter d'avoir la parole pour
vous apporter un témoignage si l'on
était besoin elle permet dans mon
département pour l'opéage novation
urbaine cœur de ville 2000 logements et
4500 habitants sont concernés seuls
trois logements ont pu être traités en
deux ans sur les 2000 possibles
le niveau de ressources ne convient pas
pour les uns et les plafonds pour les
autres vous avouerez que c'est quand
même moins que peu
merci la rapidité l'intervention
Marie-Christine Chauvin oui monsieur
madame Noël merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
directrice Madame la Directrice vous
avez parlé de la facilité pour accéder
au Parcours du système et je dois et là
vous dire qu'il y a de nombreux
dysfonctionnements et là je vais vous
parler pas d'un petit grain de sable
mais d'un énorme grain de sable qui met
un couple en grande difficulté dont le
monsieur est à mobilité réduite et il
est accompagnant de sa femme qui est
également en situation de handicap ce
dossier dure depuis juin 2021 où il a il
a alerté son compte son compte ma prime
rénove a semble-t-il été piraté le
compte a été bloqué et depuis cette date
il demande quand lui supprime ce compte
pour qu'il puisse en créer un autre et à
ce jour et bien la situation n'est
toujours pas résolue il a sollicité une
dérogation pour pouvoir faire ses
travaux c'est pour une installation à
chaudière granulés bois il a passé
l'hiver
2021-2022 sans chauffage et la l'hiver
est là et son chauffage n'est toujours
pas installé donc il me semble que la
situation est vraiment dramatique dans
cette fois il menace d'alerter les
médias parce que il n'a pas de réponse
moi j'ai également signalé le problème
on m'a dit qu'on allait contacter le
monsieur pour l'aider mais il n'y a
toujours pas d'avancer donc comment
comment aider ce monsieur pour la
dérogation on lui dit de joindre les
documents par le par votre site
évidemment il est bloqué il ne peut pas
joindre par le site il a tout envoyé par
mail il y a 15 jours et à ce jour il
attend toujours la réponse donc vraiment
je pense que la situation est urgente à
résoudre merci Marie-Christine Sylviane
Noël ensuite Henri Cabanel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice j'aurais
souhaité avoir plus d'informations sur
l'émission de mon accompagnateur Renov
escau de là des conseils donnés aux
particuliers pour les diriger vers les
travaux d'économie d'énergie les plus
appropriées est-ce que se tir de
confiance aura également pour rôle de
les accompagner dans leur démarche
administrative car pour l'avoir vécu
personnellement et pour être plutôt
aguerri au lourdeur administrative et à
l'outil informatique je peux
personnellement témoigner que c'est un
vrai parcours du combattant je rejoins
les nombreux témoignages qui m'ont
précédé et que la moindre erreur peut
amener et bien tout simplement à se voir
privé de ces aides c'est ma première
question est-ce qu'il y aurait pas quand
même nécessité de mettre en oeuvre un
principe de droit à l'erreur comme on le
connaît aujourd'hui endroit
administratif pour ne pas priver des
particuliers de bonne foi qui auront pas
cocher la bonne case au bon moment au
bon endroit de pouvoir malgré tout
percevoir leurs aides par ailleurs il
faut en moyenne 4 mois pour entre la fin
des travaux et le déblocage des aides
que ce soit des aides de Lana ou des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ce qui
est quand même considérable quand on
connaît le montant des travaux engagés
et puis enfin est-ce qu'il existe au
niveau de l'ANAH un médiateur pour faire
face aux litiges que peuvent connaître
les usagers je pense notamment un couple
de retraités qui a fait changer sa
chaudière l'entreprise était censée
réaliser toutes les démarches chose
qu'elle n'a pas fait ou mal fait et
lorsque les travaux étaient terminés
l'entreprise a bien été payée par par
les clients en revanche eux n'ont pas
reçu l'aide promise par Lana de 5000
euros et donc sans recours possible au
bout du compte merci merci avec beaucoup
de respect peut-être que si on peut
éviter toutes les petites histoires dans
tous les voilà on gagnera un tout petit
en même temps je crois qu'on a
oui oui c'est bien sûr c'est bien sûr
c'est bien sûr révélateur
vous êtes libre de poser les questions
que vous voulez je suggère juste voilà
Henri cabane pardon oui Henri Cabanel et
ensuite le rendu plomb merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice
veut revenir essentiellement donc sur
les demandeurs qui ont été victimes de
d'entreprises donc peu scrupuleuses et
qui se trouve aujourd'hui dans des
situations donc assez difficile est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas imaginer par
rapport donc au
conseiller que vous êtes vous avez mis
en place le fait de pouvoir compter sur
ses conseillers justement en cas de
problème pour les épauler face donc à
ces entreprises peu scrupuleuses et
justement pour éviter
un nombre quand même assez important
enfin moi je vois sur mon territoire il
y a quand même quelques entreprises
presque frileuses qui ont causé beaucoup
de dégâts par rapport à des demandeurs
voir pouvoir s'il n'était pas opportun
de
mettre davantage de critères pour la
labellisation RGE des entreprises
merci beaucoup Henri Laurent Duplo
ensuite Serge mériou merci madame la
Présidente moi je voudrais poser une
question simple
une personne qui bénéficie des aides de
Lana
qui est éligible à ces aides
les travaux sont faits sur son domicile
ou sa maison
par contre cette personne
est propriétaire d'un certain patrimoine
ce patrimoine par la suite est vendu
pour plusieurs dizaines de milliers
voire centaines de milliers d'euros
est-ce que une fois que vous constatez
ces ventes Lana récupère les sommes qui
ont été versées au départ pour la
réhabilitation du logement
merci Laurent Serge mériou ensuite
Evelyne Renaud Garabedian
tu n'avais pas demandé la parole alors
merci de la brièveté de tes propos
Evelyne
est-ce que conformément recommandations
de la Cour des comptes une évaluation
des bénéfices environnementaux et
sociaux du programme étaient prévus et
la deuxième question est-ce qu'en tant
que selon vous vous avez encourager la
rénovation avec un gain énergétique qui
soit supérieur à 50%
. merci Madame directrice générale mes
collègues en ont parlé la procédure
d'accès au dispositif ma prime rénove
rencontre des difficultés comme
l'indique d'ailleurs le Défenseur des
droits dans une décision du mois
d'octobre dernier face aux
dysfonctionnements techniques qui sont
rencontrés sur la plateforme au délai de
traitement des dossiers à l'absence de
prise en compte des des avis de
dégrèvement certains demandeurs n'ont
pas pu accéder à cette aide si Lana
entend l'avenir résoudre les problèmes
comme vous l'avez indiqué des
dysfonctionnements pour permettre aux
futurs demandeurs d'accéder facilement à
cette aide quand sera-t-il de l'ensemble
des demandes qui ont précédemment été
faites et qui n'ont pas pu être réalisés
en raison des difficultés qui étaient
imputables à la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif merci de votre réponse
merci Evelyne Daniel salmon ensuite
Anne-Catherine Loisier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice générale
je ne reviendrai pas sur le maquis
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
effectivement la recherche de lisibilité
est toujours là votre exposé était très
touffue mais on voit bien que c'est très
complexe je reviendrai juste une
question vous avez parlé des rénovations
par geste qui ne doivent pas être qui
doivent être prises en compte pourtant
toutes les études montrent qu'il faut
aller vers des rénovations globales et
que c'est vraiment le maître mot pour
avoir une efficience doit-on continuer à
rembourser à aider les rénovations pour
un geste ou deux geste voilà moi c'est
c'est ma question et la citation
l'incitation montre aussi ses limites
l'obligation est-ce que pensez-vous de
l'obligation par exemple sur les
multipropriétaires bailleurs parce qu'on
sait on parle souvent du petit
propriétaire bailleur mais il y a
souvent des multiples propriétaires
merci
ce qui est encore un côté gauche à côté
droit dans cette salle c'est parfait
Anne-Catherine Loisier madame Martine
Berthet monsieur le Président Madame
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces infos moi
j'aurais juste de petites questions
complémentaires pour mesurer
l'efficacité du dispositif à ce stade
vous avez parlé de 163000 madame
logement rénové je voudrais savoir
l'évolution en terme de classement de
ces logements et
et en matière de zonage est-ce que vous
avez un classement zonage urbain ou
ruraux merci
merci beaucoup Anne-Catherine Martine
Berthet ensuite Micheline Jack oui merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice moi
j'aimerais vous parler des propriétaires
bailleurs dans l'immobilier touristique
de montagne la loi climat est résiliente
2021 faisait une exception jusque-là
mais des démarches sont-elles tout de
même engagées par des propriétaires ou
déco propriétaire Emmanuel vargon
parlait de la mise en oeuvre possible
une foncière immobilière par la Caisse
des Dépôts
lors d'une réponse à une question orale
est-ce qu'il a une future obligation je
pense aux annonces du ministre Olivier
Klein fin octobre sur une chaîne TV
merci
merci beaucoup Martine Micheline Jacques
nous emmène au Microsoft
Monsieur le Directeur Madame la
Directrice générale
pendant le monsieur le Président
excusez-moi à la faveur du audition
réalisée en 2021 dans le cadre de
rapport sur le logement outre-mer à
l'initiative de la délégation
cinématoriale aux outre-mer vous nous
avez indiqué Madame la Directrice que
l'action de Lana se limitait au
dispositif ma prime rénaux seul 700
dossiers avaient été engagés en 2020
dans les quatre cinquièmes concernés la
Réunion alors qu'il n'y en avait aucun
Guyane et à Mayotte pour vais vous
indiquer si ce chiffre s'est amélioré si
la disparité entre les territoires
est-elle toujours aussi prononcé par
ailleurs des adaptations pour une
meilleure articulation entre les
financements via la LBU et les aides de
Lana étaient en cours de réflexion qu'en
est-il
merci Micheline Patrick Chauvet ensuite
Patricia Schlinger merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice au regard des échanges que
nous avons et pour en avoir vécu j'ai
une question très courte et très simple
vous avez prochainement un conseil
administration allez-vous envisager ou
proposer l'hypothèse de la
simplification merci à vous
merci Patrick et Patricia silinger oui
dernièrement il y a eu un reportage
l'interrogation
d'isolation de de camping de de
maisons qui sont en location sur
temporairement ou saisonnier et il y a
des parfois des choses assez artistiques
donc de en location et demander s'il
faisait partie aussi des aides
financières
merci beaucoup
au menu un grand nombre de questions
mais quelques thèmes récurrents je pense
alors je vais commencer sur les dossiers
en difficulté puisque
vous nous avez fait partager un certain
nombre de difficultés
la première chose je reviens sur les
chiffres qui vous ont été présentés par
le président
en début de en début d'audition Lana
prend 25 000 décisions par semaine donc
il y a 25
000 mais non mais il y a 25000 ménages
qui chaque semaine bénéficie de ma prime
rénov soit en engagement soit en
paiement la défenseur des doigts a
remonté
500 dossiers
c'est 50% de ces dossiers étaient
traités au moment de cette décision des
dossiers en difficulté existent existent
vous me les envoyez vous me les
transmettez on va les traiter ça c'est
le premier point
c'est voilà c'est la proposition c'est
la proposition la proposition
vous me les envoyez non mais
vous me les envoyer
et on reçoit
on reçoit régulièrement on reçoit
régulièrement des sollicitations de
parlementaires avec des dossiers qui
sont réglés effectivement il y en a il y
en aura toujours je souhaite vous le
dire il n'existe pas de système parfait
et derrière ces dossiers en difficulté
il y a eu des dysfonctionnements de la
plateforme en 2020 mais il y a aussi
effectivement des ménages qui n'arrivent
pas ou des entreprises qui n'arrivent
pas à nous déposer des dossiers complets
qui n'arrive pas à déposer des dossiers
complets des factures non-acquittées des
factures qui ne correspondent pas aux
travaux réalisés
des contrôles sur place des contrôles
des contrôles sur place qui sont
diligées par l'agence qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas reçus par les ménages
qui refusent de recevoir la personne qui
vient faire des contrôles sur place le
paiement est bloqué je ne dis pas que
les cas que vous avez à me faire
remonter correspondre à ça mais voilà la
typologie des difficultés que nous
rencontrons c'est de l'argent public qui
est distribué dans un certain nombre de
conditions qui doivent être respectés et
l'agent comptable de l'agence ne paye
pas des dossiers qui sont irréguliers
donc effectivement parfois il faut
passer du temps sur un certain dossier
mais je reçois en tout cas l'ensemble de
vos demandes pour faire en sorte qu'elle
soit réglées s'ils peuvent si elles
peuvent être réglées deuxième point le
lien entre les la plateforme nationale
la plateforme téléphonique et numérique
nationale et le local ces liens existent
il y a un transfert d'appel qui a été
mis en place dès 2020 les espaces
conseils France rénovent l'utilisent
pour certains ne l'utilisent pas pour
d'autres c'est aussi des positions
individuelles ou collectives mais le
transfert d'appel c'est-à-dire j'ai un
usagé ma prime rénov qui est bloqué avec
son dossier le transfert d'appel direct
vers les services au niveau national
existent il est très bien utilisé par
certains espaces conseils France rénov
il ne l'est pas par d'autres mais pour
autant il existe il a été mis en place
et certains espaces conseils France
rénovent ont même échangé avec les
services de l'agence au niveau national
pour régler un certain nombre de
dossiers mais l'instruction se fait bien
au niveau national c'est une plateforme
qui a été mise en place qui traite je le
rappelle 25 000 demandes par semaine et
qui aujourd'hui ne relève pas du local
parce que si ça relevait du local vous
voyez à peu près le type de création
d'emplois que ça nécessiterait et
l'ingénierie que cela nécessiterait mais
le transfert d'appel existe troisième
élément effectivement il n'y a pas
d'accompagnement obligatoire autour de
ma prime rénov nationale aujourd'hui
d'où la mise en place de cet
accompagnateur obligatoire à partir d'un
certain montant de travaux à compter du
premier janvier prochain qui va
permettre d'accompagner les ménages dans
ce parcours parce que le parcours reste
un parcours de travaux et d'accès à des
aides publiques qui sont complexes la
plateforme m'imprimerait 9 n'est pas une
plateforme de type
marchande ce n'est pas une plateforme on
commande un chauffeur ou on commande un
plat c'est une demande d'argent public
sur la base de d'un dossier qui doit
être constitué et qui doit être conforme
à la réglementation
l'éloignement pour des ménages qui sont
loin du numérique j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure que effectivement
l'accompagnement est une un des éléments
de réponse mais aussi le lien avec les
maisons françaises qui est extrêmement
important et qui a déjà été mis en place
dans certains territoires et ensuite par
rapport aux espaces ruraux j'ai fait un
tour de France cette année en année 2022
et dans la majorité des régions j'ai
constaté que certains territoires qui
avaient des espaces ruraux
particulièrement importants avaient mis
en place une itinérance de France rénov
c'est-à-dire des rencontres sur des
marchés des rencontres dans des espaces
France services des rencontres dans des
locaux divers et variés avec des prises
de rendez-vous et des ménages qui se
déplacent donc au moment où c'est
permanent sont assurés suivants un
planning tout à fait intéressant et qui
montre bien que cette politique publique
effectivement ne se met pas en œuvre
exactement de la même manière dans
l'espace urbain que dans l'espace
dans l'espace rural
sur le du coup je la question que vous
avez posée sur Épernay je peux pas y
répondre comme ça moi j'ai besoin de
savoir s'il y a une opération programmée
d'amélioration de l'habitat quel est le
voilà et quels sont les freins en fait
par rapport aux questions que vous
soulevez mais inaptracto tant que j'ai
pas le dossier sous les yeux c'est
difficile de savoir qu'elles peuvent
être les éléments bloquants en fait que
vous avez que vous avez que vous avez
signalé je reviens sur mon
accompagnateur Renov les missions qui
sont prévues par le décret et qui vont
être confirmés pour la constitution du
dossier par arrêter relève de quatre
ordres le premier c'est évidemment un
accompagnement technique
relatif aux travaux un accompagnement
administratif relatif donc à
l'accompagnement dans le parcours de
demande d'aide un accompagnement
économique et financier pour permettre
aux ménage de comprendre quel est le
montant de travaux et quels sont les
aides existantes qui lui de solvabilité
d'être solvabilité et un quatrième et un
quatrième une quatrième mission pardon
social notamment pour les ménages les
plus vulnérables et qui peuvent être
dans des situations de logement très
complexes qui ne correspondent pas
toujours qu'à une réalisation de travaux
sur le sujet des entreprises peu
scrupuleuses oui il y en a c'est pas la
majorité il en existe il y a un label
RGE effectivement auquel la proportion
de d'entreprises qui ont accédé est
aujourd'hui encore insuffisant et qui
n'est pas systématiquement la garantie
ultime
j'ai pas enfin voilà je constate avec
vous mais je pense que c'est des
questions qui doivent être posées au
ministère et pas simplement à
l'opérateur quelle agence nationale de
l'habitat
et au réseau et aux têtes de réseau
nationaux national pardon
donc voilà sur le sur les gains
énergétiques plus 50% de gains
énergétiques effectivement en moyenne
sur la rénovation globale c'est en
moyenne un saut de deux étiquettes
donc voilà avec plus de 50% des
logements qui ont bénéficié qui sont
sortis de leur statut de passoire
thermique
bien entendu de l'âge du logement et de
évidemment du type de travaux qui a été
réalisé
et
ensuite deux autres questions
celles sur les propriétaires bailleurs
alors et d'une manière générale sur les
propriétaires à partir du moment où un
propriétaire sollicite une aide de
l'ANAH il s'engage il s'engage à occuper
le logement pendant un certain nombre
d'années où il se cage à louer le
logement par un certain nombre d'années
et à partir du moment où ce logement est
cédé quel que soit les raisons nous
avons un pôle qui s'appelle le pôle de
contrôle des engagements qui engage des
campagnes régulières pour pouvoir
s'assurer que ces engagements sont tenus
donc avec des contrôles sur place et par
ailleurs nous sommes aussi en lien avec
les notaires qui nous font connaître
parce qu'ils savent quand le logement a
bénéficié de cette aide et qui nous font
volonté effectivement ces sessions donc
il y a un service spécialisé à l'agence
qui s'occupe effectivement du contrôle
de ces engagements et des recouvrements
potentiels en cas de non-respect
effectivement des engagements des
propriétaires et en ce qui concerne donc
les propriétaires les propriétaires
bailleurs multi-propriétaires les aides
de la NAS sont limitées à trois
logements donc ce sont des propriétaires
bailleurs qui possèdent au maximum trois
logements et qui sont soumis de toute
façon à ces obligations de location sur
une durée qui évidemment est contrôlée
au travers des engagements qui sont que
j'évoquais à l'instant et enfin sur la
question de l'immobilier touristique de
par la loi et de par la réglementation
Lana n'intervient que sur les résidences
principales et absolument pas sur
l'immobilier touristique et dernière
question j'allais l'oublier
pardonnez-moi l'outre-mer donc en
outre-mer effectivement les aides de
Lana il n'y avait pas jusqu'à ma prime
rénov il y avait pas d'aide aux
propriétaires occupants tout simplement
personne ne s'occuper que des
propriétaires bailleurs puisque les
aides aux propriétaires occupants sont
délivrés par le ministère des Outre-mer
au travers de la ligne budgétaire unique
donc il y a eu effectivement une
ouverture aux propriétaires occupants
via ma prime rénov et les dynamiques
sont extrêmement intéressantes et
réellement en courbe croissance depuis
et elles sont elles sont en ligne sur le
site de l'ANAH merci beaucoup Madame la
Directrice monsieur le Président voulait
rajouter quelques précisions uniquement
des précisions puisque générale a
apporté beaucoup de réponses pour vous
dire que
moi je ne sous-estime pas les les
dossiers sur lesquels individuels sur
lesquels il y a des difficultés
étant moi-même certains le savent mère
d'une ville de 60 000 habitants je
mesure parfois y compris leur des
réunions publiques ou des demandes de
mes propres concitoyens leur remarque
sur les difficultés des dispositifs que
je mets moi-même en place comme mère
et parfois effectivement
ils peuvent pas avoir accès à certains
services parce que la plateforme
municipale n'a pas prévu le cas de
figure ou lorsque vous dépassez le
quotient familial vous avez plus droit à
un certain nombre de choses et quand
vous avez un dispositif où il y a de
l'argent public qui est engagé il y a
des contrôles et il y a une certaine
parfois rigidité qui est mise en place
pour s'assurer
que l'argent est utilisé à bon escient
et je suis moi-même destinataire à
Chambéry de dossier
de certains de vos collègues qui
m'écrivent directement en disant
monsieur le Président voilà j'ai un cas
particulier
alors c'est quoi le particulier ben la
personne par exemple qui engagé les
travaux est décédé
donc pour le paiement bon on peut pas
payer parce qu'il faut on a des règles
juridiques faut attendre quelle est la
succession qui aura la charge du dossier
les travaux ne sont pas à la bonne
adresse alors bon c'est un problème
parce qu'en fait c'est un bâtiment
d'angle il y avait deux entrées le
dossier était monté sur une adresse et
les factures ont été adressées sur une
autre adresse
non mais je vous parle de cas vraiment
qui qui sont la réalité
il y a un dossier donc qui est donné
avec un avis favorable avec le montant
de la subvention avec les entreprises
qui sont listées
cette obligatoire puisque nous on doit
le faire avec des entreprises RGE on se
rend compte que quand le dossier arrive
pour le paiement c'est pas les
entreprises qui étaient voilà elles sont
pas RGE et bah qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
peut pas parce que si vous n'êtes pas
labellisé voilà je vais même vous donner
deux cas de figure dont je ne veux pas
que vous pensiez que c'est la règle mais
nous avons des dossiers qui sont montés
sur la plateforme puisque maintenant on
passe par des plateformes informatiques
avec des vraies familles qui déposent
des dossiers qui disent voilà le nombre
de ce qu'on doit faire comme travaux le
calcul de la prime des devis
d'entreprises RGE labellisées qui
existent sur vos territoires quelques
mois après les factures arrivent
factures acquittées
donc il y a paiement de ces factures et
parfois on se rend compte que ni les
ménages concernés ni les entreprises qui
ont envoyé des devis
n'existent dans la réalité c'est à dire
c'est des vrais ménages
c'est des vrais entreprises mais il y a
des systèmes aussi aujourd'hui il faut
se le dire
organisationnels qui ont mis en place de
faux dossiers et donc comprenez aussi
que tous ces cas de fraude
oblige et c'est normal la direction
générale d'être encore plus vigilant
parce que nous avons aussi des comptes à
rendre à nos tutelles financières les
ministères pour savoir si l'argent
dépensé est bien dépensé tel que vous
l'avez collectivement voulu dans les
textes de loi et les
discussions budgétaires les projets de
loi de finances qui permettent à Lana
d'avoir ses moyens franchement voilà il
y a des difficultés parfois techniques
en 2020 me semble-t-il il y avait de
l'ordre de 6 à 7000 dossiers individuels
qui étaient planté et sans doute y
a-t-il des dossiers que vous avez connus
sur vos territoires il y en a encore
quelques centaines aujourd'hui c'est à
dire il y a une tasse force qui a été
mise en place au sein de l'agence avec
des gens spécialisés pour aller
individuellement voir quelle est la
nature du blocage et je vous le dis il y
a une pression qui est mise sur la
direction générale à la fois par le
président mais aussi par le gouvernement
pour résoudre ces cas individuels pour
faire la différenciation entre les
quatre fraudes il y en a malheureusement
beaucoup dans notre pays je vous dis de
vraies dossiers de vrais familles et
quand on fait des contrôles sur place de
plus en plus on dit mais attendez j'ai
jamais déposé de dossier pour acheter un
poêle à granules qu'est-ce que c'est
j'ai attendu madame monsieur c'est bien
vous et l'entreprise qui est au coin de
la rue qui a certifié la facture oui oui
c'est vrai mais on n'a jamais déposé de
dossier voilà donc tout cela pour vous
dire que parce qu'il y a aussi de
l'argent public il y a des contrôles qui
doivent être stricts mais
en résoudra en épurera la liste qui peut
à peu je vous assure partie de 6 à 7000
dossiers en 2020 aujourd'hui se limite à
quelques centaines alors je vais revenir
aussi sur un sujet sur les 80% de
logements de 2050 qui existent
aujourd'hui puisque des questions
est-ce que
est-ce que le rythme de construction
aujourd'hui permettra de répondre à la
demande de nos concitoyens à être logés
alors ça c'est une question qui
appartient plutôt au ministre du
Logement et pas à l'établissement public
de Lana qui est là pour accompagner les
logements déjà construits ceci étant la
question de la seconde vie est une
question fondamentale parce que on est
un pays en démographie positive que sur
nos territoires vous allez comme le
maire de Chambéry d'ailleurs de voir
appliquer un texte qui s'appelle le zéro
artificialisation net et donc que nous
avons un engagement international sur la
stratégie nationale bas carbone 0 en
2050 ça veut dire qu'effectivement
le gisement pour ne loger nos
concitoyens massivement et dans les
logements déjà existants qu'ils devront
être reconfiguré globalement en termes
thermiques mais aussi en termes de
profil pour répondre à la demande de nos
concitoyens des grands logements petits
logements enfin bref chacun sur son
territoire voit de ce dont il s'agit et
plus on remettra sur le sur le marché
des logements y compris vacants puisqu'à
10% de logements vacants en France plus
on arrivera à résoudre cette équation de
loger plus le Gmail et plus d'ailleurs
on m'intégrera les logements vacants
plus ça laissera de la souplesse sur les
territoires ruraux pour le zan c'est
contre intuitif mais tant que vous plus
vous investissez sur l'existant plus
vous laissez de la disponibilité sur des
terrains qui sont aujourd'hui libres
pour le secteur périphérique dans
l'importance que nous plaidons nous sur
les fonds friches par exemple pour
qu'ils puissent y avoir notre
alors le fond friche inséré dans le fond
vert j'ai cru que c'était à peu près
comme ça pour que l'on puisse ne plus
imperméabiliser voilà
de sujets puisque il y avait cette
question sur
les logements nouveaux et les logements
à retaper je suis désolé il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses et sur les
CRC
CRC 16h il faut vraiment prendre les
rapports avec un certain
recul parce que très vite au bout de
quelques semaines parfois ils ne sont
plus d'actualité tellement les choses
vont vite sur la réorganisation même du
service et le traitement d'un certain
nombre de dossiers en disant cela je
sais pas si on m'écoutera la CRC je
ressens d'autres convoqué mais c'est la
réalité et quand on publie un rapport en
disant il y a 500 dossiers qui sont
plantés ça c'est plutôt la Défenseur des
droits que dans l'arrêt il y en a 250 en
quelques jours les choses évoluent
énormément voilà
si vous permettez Daniel salmon a oublié
un petit élément
le président de me redonner la parole
vous parliez d'argent public tout de
suite est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
un mot sur les 30 millions dépensés par
Lana auprès de cabinet de conseils merci
effectivement enfin il y a pas de
sujet là dessus il y a eu une commission
et nous avons répondu et transmis les
éléments Lana effectivement fait appel
des cabinets de conseils à un cabinet de
conseil en particulier avec lequel nous
sommes en marché tout à fait régulier
validé en conseil d'administration pour
développer ma prime rénove pour
développer France rainove et c'est
développement évidemment un coup ce sont
des développements informatiques je
précise enfin il faut que les choses
soient claires le sujet n'est pas de
nous dire quel type de politique
publique nous sommes en train de
développer la politique publique autour
de la rénovation énergétique il s'agisse
des aides ou qu'il s'agisse de
l'accompagnement et qu'il s'agisse donc
d'une générique sont des sujets qui sont
traités par les sphères ministérielles
concernées qui sont décidés évidemment
en interministériel à Matignon et qui
ensuite sont mises en œuvre par
l'opérateur que nous sommes et nous
faisons appel effectivement à des
cabinet de conseils en l'occurrence nous
avons acheté aussi des produits
informatiques pour développer cette
plateforme et ça fait partie
effectivement de de la régularité des
marchés qui sont posés par l'agence pour
pouvoir répondre aux missions qui lui
ont été confiées par le gouvernement
vous m'avez enfin j'avais une question
sur les délais puisque
ça a été évoqué à l'heure où nous nous
parlons je vous dis que les choses
évoluent vite c'est-à-dire que
l'info d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle
d'il y a deux ans le délai d'instruction
d'un dossier qui est déposé qui est
complet qui est donc apporté il y a
toutes les devis en quelque sorte des
entreprises le dossier de traitement
pour avoir un feu vert aujourd'hui c'est
neuf jours sur Lana pour engager les
travaux
le délai de paiement une fois que les
factures ont été acquittées le
remboursement aujourd'hui c'est 15 jours
une fois que le dossier est déposé je
voudrais aussi dire que pour les plus
modestes il existe des dispositifs
d'avance sur subvention c'est-à-dire que
l'argent l'aurait
apporté en attendant que Lana leur
remboursera les subventions auxquelles
les endroits à travers plusieurs
dispositifs notamment le dispositif des
sacycapes prosivis sur vos territoires
qui apportent des subventions pour les
ménages les plus modestes font l'avance
et seront remboursés par ces mêmes
ménages dès lors qu'il toucheront les
les subventions de de l'ANAH il existe
aussi des prêts qui ont été mises en
place à la suite d'une mission qui a
conduit monsieur Sichel de la banque des
territoires le prêt avance mutation
distribue aujourd'hui par deux réseaux
la Banque Postale elle Crédit Mutuel si
ma mémoire est bonne parce que je m'y
perds parfois qui sont des crédits
spécifiques pour des gens qui s'engagent
dans des rénovations qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de le faire soit
sur lequel le capital sera remboursé
ultérieurement notamment quand il y a
une mutation du logement qui a fait
l'objet des rénovations c'est notamment
utile à la fois pour les plus modestes
mais parfois pour les plus âgés sur
lesquels les banques
je vais dire chose compte tenues de
l'espérance de vie des requérants
étaient très réticents à apporter des
avances ce prêt nouveau qui a été créé
il y a une année qui est pas encore très
connue mais c'est aussi le l'opportunité
pour moi de vous dire qu'il existe c'est
de renvoyer parfois des ménages qui ont
des difficultés avec des banques
classiques de les renvoyer vers ces deux
réseaux puisque ce prêt est aujourd'hui
en place
c'est une vraie question ce que l'on
observe c'est que
ce sont plutôt des ménage modestes qui
s'engagent par geste sur une
programmation plus riche annuelle et que
il faut bien
avoir la réflexion collective de savoir
si on les supprime en disant vous
n'allez que sur une Renault collective
de savoir ce que deviennent les demandes
de ces ménages
madame ma directrice générale je crois
que Monsieur Duplo n'a pas obtenu
exactement la réponse qu'il voilà c'est
sur le remboursement des personnes qui
obtiennent des aides de Lana et qui
ensuite vendent dans des délais très
courts leurs biens avec une plus-value
voilà je crois que vous avez répondu
mais
un moment donné
que après il faisait vendu une partie de
leur capital est-ce que on va récupérer
comment on fait pour les hommes sur une
succession on va récupérer ces aides
dans le capital qu'ils ont vendu ou pas
question
alors sur ce sur ce point la
situation fiscale du ménage qui demande
une aide à l'agence et celle de l'année
en cours
non si tu gagnes au loto non plus
[Rires]
très bien voilà souhaitez-vous ajouter
quelque chose
non s'il vous plaît non pas
particulièrement mais vous remercier
pour les échanges qui je pense ont
permis de lever beaucoup de beaucoup de
points et de l'intérêt que vous portez à
cette rénovation énergétique et à
l'amélioration de l'habitat privé je le
redis c'est une politique publique qui
évolue et qui a quelques années
d'existence donc il ne peut que
s'améliorer et il faut il faut faire en
sorte qu'elle s'améliore dans les années
à venir pour que un maximum de ménage
qui sont comme le disait le président
tout à l'heure pas occupant du parc
social mais bien propriétaire d'un
logement pas maître d'ouvrage pas
spécialiste des questions d'habitat
puisse s'engager le plus sereinement
possible dans ces démarches de travaux
c'est indispensable dans des enjeux
évidemment de qualité du logement dans
notre pays et bien sûr de qualité de
l'air et évidemment de de lut contre le
réchauffement climatique merci Madame la
Directrice Générale mot de la fin vous
revient monsieur le Président je demande
l'attention de mes collègues s'il vous
plaît merci
à vous toutes et tous qui est très
nombreuses ce matin à vous intéresser à
ce sujet
qui concerne la partie de la France des
propriétaires
puisqu'on a souvent tendance à scinder
les propriétaires publics et les
propriétaires privés en l'occurrence ce
matin c'est effectivement la partie des
Français qui sont propriétaires
occupants bailleurs ou
multipropriétaires ou dans des
copropriétés pour vous dire qu'on a je
pense un intérêt
vous comme
à l'initiative des politiques publiques
et l'opérateur se soit un vrai succès
compte tenu je le répète des engagements
que notre pays a pris à l'occasion de
différentes cops notamment la COP de 21
qui a eu lieu à Paris que la France a
été condamnée deux fois sur la scène
internationale pour des manquements
vis-à-vis de des politiques en matière
environnementale et que je le redis
c'est ma conviction la politique du
logement on est à la convergence des
politiques sociales
économique d'aménagement du territoire
et qui évidemment l'établissement public
qui est au service de la nation et de
vos territoires
fera et se déplora pour répondre à la
demande des pouvoirs publics donc nous
suivons avec grand intérêt les travaux
qui se font à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat à l'occasion des votes de
projets de loi de finance notamment mais
également de loi qui ont très à
l'environnement parce que c'est là que
nous puissions nous puisons pardon à la
fois nos ressources mais aussi la raison
d'être de l'ANAH voilà merci beaucoup
merci Madame la Directrice Générale
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
dire en conclusion que je rappelle que à
l'ordre du jour de la conférence des
présidents la semaine prochaine il y
aura la possibilité de répondre aux
droits de tirage du groupe du groupe
geste et qui fait une proposition de
résolution pendant la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur l'efficacité
des politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
donc je pense qu'une partie de notre non
c'est pas que logement c'est bâtiment
d'une façon générale mais dont le
logement donc je pense que cette
commission d'enquête aura l'occasion de
vous resolicité pour une autre audition
voilà je vous en ai accepté alors je
vous remercie infiniment d'avoir répondu
rapidement à notre invitation et j'ai
bien pris madame le point qu'on vous
envoie les dossiers voilà